As we celebrate the golden anniversary of
the Protein Data Bank, let’s look at the
history and the milestones that shaped it
to become the essential resource for research
and education it is today.
The Protein Data Bank was established in 1971.
In its first years the archive was very small
and contained a few groundbreaking structures.
For each structure, the PDB contained the
three-dimensional coordinates, or the x, y,
and z positions of each atom.
How did the scientists “see” the atoms?
Back in the 1970s, the sole method to do so
was X-ray crystallography.
Proteins form crystals when they are purified
and concentrated.
Within the crystal, many copies of the protein
are arranged in symmetrical arrays.
When an x-ray beam strikes the crystal, the
x-rays scatter into a distinctive pattern
of spots.
These x-ray diffraction patterns are then
analyzed to determine the positions of atoms
in the protein.
In 1913, the father-son team, Henry and Lawrence
Bragg were the first to describe how to interpret
the X-ray diffraction patterns.
They used a sodium chloride or salt crystal
for their experiments.
Later, the Braggs mentored many world class
researchers who used X-ray crystallography
on a variety of increasingly complex substances.
In 1958, using X-ray crystallography, John
Kendrew determined the first atomic structure
of a protein, myoglobin.
With that, the field of structural biology
was born.
More and more scientists started to study
the 3D structures of proteins and by the early
and by the early 1970's, there were a dozen atomic structures
solved in different labs.
Researchers around the world were interested
in exploring what these 3D structures revealed.
However, data sharing was difficult in the
time before the Internet.
Early PDB structures were stored on paper
punch cards, each containing information about
1 atom.
The Protein Data Bank archive was established
to solve this problem.
The scientists deposited the data to the PDB
and the PDB copied the data onto magnetic
tapes and distributed them to researchers
upon request.
In October 1980, 10 years after the PDB was
established, there were more than 150 structures
in the archive available for distribution.
In October 1980, 10 years after the PDB was
established, the PDB archive holdings contained
151 structures available for distribution.
A year later, the first DNA structure was
added to the PDB.
In 1989, the first structure determined by
a biophysical method called Nuclear Magnetic
Resonance Spectroscopy or NMR was deposited
to the PDB.
In this method, a purified protein is mixed
with special solvent and inserted into an
NMR probe.
The protein sample is then exposed to a strong
magnetic field.
This makes the nuclei of certain atoms, like
hydrogen, spin like tops.
When the sample is probed with radio waves,
the nuclei become excited and resonate.
The frequencies are measured and recorded.
The surroundings of the atoms determine how
high, or how low the frequencies are.
Using computational methods, the measurements
are converted into a graph that represents
the frequencies as peaks with specific locations
for specific atom groups.
This information is further refined and combined
with additional NMR experiments to determine
the 3D structure.
The NMR method proved to be effective in solving
3D structures of smaller proteins and gave
us a unique glimpse of how proteins behave
in solution.
In 1991, the first structure determined using
3D Electron Microscopy or 3DEM was released
by the PDB.
In this method, a tiny amount of purified
protein is placed onto a copper grid.
A special machine spreads the sample in a
single layer on the grid.
The sample is frozen in liquid ethane and
then loaded into an electron microscope.
The sample is exposed to a beam of accelerated
electrons and images are captured.
Usually, the proteins are in many different
orientations.
The images are then grouped by orientation
and then combined computationally to reconstruct
the 3D shape of a molecule.
Atoms are fit into the map to derive the 3D
structure of the protein.
3DEM has become a perfect complement to X-ray
and NMR techniques.
The method is very effective on large, complex
assemblies that are typically difficult to
study by either of the two older methods.
In 1995, the PDB Archive became accessible
for the first time through a www website.
The PDB holdings were accessible online through
various services since 1988.
However, the new website equipped with a browser
marked a new chapter in data distribution.
Researchers could still request the full archive
on CD ROM.
In 1999, the 10,000th structure was released
into the PDB.
The distribution of the PDB archive on physical
media was discontinued in 2004.
By then the Internet and computer technology
made it possible for all data operations to
be done completely online through the FTP
server and web portals maintained by the members
of the newly established worldwide PDB organization.
In 2008, the PDB archive reached another milestone
number of entries: 50,000 structures.
In 2014, the number doubled.
As the PDB entered its golden year, there
were more than 170,000 structures in the archive.
The growing numbers of 3D structures of proteins
and nucleic acids further our understanding
of biology and help us explore how life works
at the atomic level.
Many Nobel Prizes have been awarded for projects
involving molecular structures.
Structural biology research is essential in
addressing major public health emergencies.
For example, scientists have used the structures
of HIV proteins to design drugs that stop
the virus from multiplying.
Today, as the world faces the COVID pandemic,
structural biologists are exploring its viral
proteins in a quest for new therapeutics and
vaccines.
The PDB provides ready access to structural
biology research ensuring the quality of the
data and providing tools for query, visualization
and analysis of these structures.
Now, 50 years since the PDB’s founding,
the Protein Data Bank continues to be a leading
global resource for experimental data that
is playing a central role in scientific discovery
and education.